-Guys, it is time for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every week where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond to that topic.
With the Oscars happening this weekend,
I sent out the hashtag "IDeserveAnAward."
And I asked you guys to tweet out a funny or weird thing
that you think you deserve an award for.
Within minutes, it was a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
And now I thought I'd share some of my favorite
#IDeserveAnAward tweets from you guys.
Here we go. This first one's from @Sohnzie. She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's hard to do. That's self-control.
-That's an award. Yeah.
-This one's from @DunLahfAtMae. [don't laugh at me]
-Ahh. [Valley girl accent] What does this say?
-D-U-N-L-A-H-F -- Anyway. Dunlahf.
-Dunlahf. -She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
At least you're polite. -Yeah.
-This one's from @thefabulouspot6. She says...
Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hot!
-This one's from @sophierhi13. She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"How fresh is the, uh, muttza-rell?"
Manna-got.
-Gabbagol. -Gabbagool.
They're like, "Yeah, we don't say that in Italy."
-Yeah.
-This one's from @elise-millsssss.
They say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This one's from @lasbishopmusic. They say...
That's a -- That's a superpower.
Boom!
This last one is from @2much2do55. She says...
"I'm a teacher."
-Yeah! -That's right. That's right.
Those are our "Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.